buongiorno ignorate la cravatta menestò
pentendo sempre di più questa mattina
poteva farne a meno
mi chiamo umberto nicolini sono un
architetto urbanista grazie per essere
qua in un sabato di pioggia in cambio
faccio voto di non annoiarvi con troppi
tecnicismi abbandono la mia coperta di
linus e quindi magari modifica un po
quello che probabilmente di dire dunque
io sono un architetto sono un architetto
quindi mi occupo di oggetti nel mio
lavoro mi occupo di oggetti di diverse
scale siano essi oggetti di design fino
arrivare alle città mi occupo di persone
mi occupo di persone perché i fatti
umani si svolgono dentro lo spazio che
viene progettato
cominciamo male mi direte voi un pò di
banalità per cominciare ecco davanti a
questa affermazione così banale e così
vera lo spazio il contenuto dei fatti
umani abbiamo tradizionalmente ha avuto
due risposte due tipi di risposte in
passato una che arriva per lo più da chi
si occupa della società dal punto di
vista umano quella di sottovalutare
l'influenza dello spazio all'interno del
come causa degli eventi o come concausa
un'altra quella degli architetti dei
cari colleghi ecco questo primo
approccio ormai possiamo dire che è
stato abbandonato buona parte
l'atteggiamento dei cari colleghi e
quello invece di essere formati
tutt'oggi purtroppo come dei demiurghi
l'architetto viene cresciuto per lo più
nella convinzione che il suo intervento
determini fatti umani
quindi lo spazio non è un contenuto
semplicemente c'è un contenitore scusate
ma è l'unico oggetto che determina
l'esistenza delle persone
con la conseguenza del l'idea che la
bellezza risolva i problemi la bellezza
formale
ecco dopo questa introduzione polemica
che prima o poi mi farà cacciare
dall'ordine
passo a illustrarvi perché sono qua oggi
ho mandato io
questa mattina per fare per iniziare con
un esempio
prendendo la 91 21 al filobus pc che fa
la circonvallazione di milano gira quasi
tutta la notte a una pausa di un paio
d'ore e sulla 91 si possono si può
assistere episodi interessantissimi che
ha l'occasione di e all'interesse può
venire a milano fare un giro notturno di
due tre ore sulla 91 e per assistere a
qualunque tipo di avvenimento in una
quota vengono città questa mattina ho
preso davanti alle sei e mezza
e come sempre come conosco
metà del filobus era occupato da persone
che due fermate prima arrivano da
all'ortomercato di milano
soprattutto asiatici
con degli enormi pacchi di
verdure raccolti all'ortomercato
comprati a lato mancato per poi andrà
essere distribuiti nei vari ristoranti
etnici
unica altra persona oltre a questi
signori ea me guidato ovviamente una
signora anziana
appena sono salito si è venuto a sedere
a fianco
una retta meno male non ve lo dico
milanese perché fare un giorno disastro
meno male che è arrivato anche lei ero
qua tutto spaventata
ora non ho fatto una fotografia perché
non ci ho pensato ho pensato dopo
l'episodio però immaginate 5 6 7 8 10
pakistan i cinesi hanno portati coverity
dalle trevano altromercato raccogliere
le offerte migliori con questi nomi
sacchi di verdura anche motore da
mercato delle erbe fantastico
quale minaccia possono rappresentare per
la signora dopo una signora anziana
signora terrorizzata ora questo è un
tipico esempio di un conflitto
chiuso entrambe le popolazioni vogliamo
definirla così ritengono con l'uso del
mezzo pubblico perfettamente normale per
loro però terra signora questo è un
problema
questo avviene in un luogo ben
determinato quindi in altri luoghi se
questi fossero stati per strada quando i
sacchi di verdura questo non sarebbe
accaduto la stessa mia posizione qua
oggi io non sapevo cosa aspettarmi
temevo la cattedra detesto questo è già
un tipo di rapporto diverso e lo spazio
non è cambiato il modo in cui lo stiamo
utilizzando diverso se io non fossi qua
al centro e vi chiedessi girare tutte le
sedie
un rapporto più interattivo lo stesso
spazio avrebbe un'altra valenza quindi
l'influenza dello spazio su quello che
facciamo è importante ma non
determinante
quindi progetto in questo bellissimo
spazio non è così influente come se
l'influenza di come lo si usa perché la
sicurezza perché credo che più o meno
quei tutti o premiate nel campo del
sociale della convivenza della
multiculturalità e credo che come me
sciopero in un altro punto di vista
siate in stufi di sentire regolarmente
l'accoppiata convivenza sicurezza sempre
in termini negativi ovviamente mai con
ormai salvo quando si va a lavorare tra
di noi michael ha valenza di convivenza
uguale più sicurezza
io ringrazio moltissimo le banche e la
finanza che quest'anno ci hanno
risparmiato una campagna elettorale
basata sui problemi di sicurezza legati
alla convivenza ricordatevi quelle
precedenti quindi noi come architetti
siamo specializzati su quello che
l'impatto sulla sicurezza
della forma urbana
se va
per cui quando l'assessore corradini mi
ha coinvolta in questo bellissimo
progetto
ho cercato di mi sono domandato quali
siano le implicazioni quale sia il
rapporto tra la sicurezza dello spazio e
la convivenza sicuramente c'è
una ricaduta della sicurezza degli spazi
sulla convivenza perché perché uno
spazio sicuro un luogo sicuro
ha determinate caratteristiche
e più utilizzato prima e più banale più
scontata c'è più senso di appropriazione
in un luogo sicuro le persone si sentono
parte di quel luogo si sentono di
possederlo
c'è più vitalità
ovviamente le obiezioni sono sempre
possibili quindi se qualcuno vuole
intervenire non c'è problema c'è più
condivisione
riassumendo possiamo dire che un luogo
sicuro facilita la convivenza
d'altra parte ci domandiamo quali siano
i risvolti di una buona convivenza tra
le persone tra le culture sulla
sicurezza il rapporto biunivoco quindi
quindi
dove c'è convivenza dove la convivenza
funziona ed è positiva c'è più mix
sociale culturale economico c'è più
vitalità la vitalità è una questione
fondamentale per le teorie della
sicurezza
c'è più rispetto non solo delle persone
ma anche dei luoghi che le utility che
che queste persone utilizzano e c'è più
libertà
in uno spazio dove c'è convivenza in un
luogo dove c'è convivenza c'è più
sicurezza
siccome io mi opero opero sulla
sicurezza forzatamente e volentieri
molto spesso mi trovo a lavorare con i
temi della convivente
ti darò un brevissimo accenno sul che
cosa vuol dire sicurezza oggi
allora
prima vorrei comprare non ho fatto la
premessa sgombro ogni dubbio parliamo di
sicurezza personale
avendo questo tipo di pubblico non penso
di dover specificare perché molto spesso
dopo che pago di sicurezza
contattare i pompieri piuttosto che
ingegneria strutturale
paghiamo di sicurezza delle persone
allora
oggi come oggi
quando si parla di sicurezza il termine
improprio parliamo di paura
parliamo di paura che è un'estensione è
una specie migliora specificazione del
problema la paura
fino a un po di anni fa aveva una
definizione molto semplice che
corrisponde alla prima che leggete il
rischio concreto di rimanere vittima di
un'aggressione o episodi di violenza
in passato si semplifica va dicendo la
gente ha paura perché
ha paura di essere aggredita
violentata e rapinata ora anni di studi
spero che non siano troppo banali queste
cose braccia piatto di semplificare
hanno portato alla definizione della
paura legata al territorio che è molto
più estesa in particolare un aspetto
importantissimo è la rottura dei codici
tradizionali
il comportamento che cosa vuol dire
questo è un filone che adesso ad esempio
nel mondo che lo straccione
preponderante quello che loro chiamano
anti social behaviour ma può essere
esteso anche a quello che dicevo prima
del filobus 3a la presenza di diverse
culture che hanno
tradizionalmente un uso dello spazio
diverso non sempre non sempre riescono a
rendere compatibile tra di loro e l'uso
degli spazi quindi si va da
atteggiamenti
che sono fuori dal normale comportamento
per qualunque cultura e che non sono
però per riconosciuti in quanto spesso
come non sono reati non sono crimini non
sono giustamente perseguibili eppure
l'impatto che hanno sulla percezione
delle persone è devastante
possiamo anche identificare in alcuni
ecco la mancanza di cura del territorio
qui entriamo più nell'aspetto della
gestione dello spazio quindi la gestione
dell'architettura
ora vi abbiamo fatto alcuni esempi in
questo la manutenzione dello spazio
pubblico la polizia lo spazio pubblico
il funzionamento delle cose le fermate
dell'autobus conoscono vandalizzata
hanno una ricaduta
enorme sulla persona cioè una zona di
milano la zona di via padova che forse
avrete sentito per qualche cronache
passato
che i giornali additano come la peggior
di zona di milano la gente terrorizzata
via padova una zona di fatto centrale di
piazzale loreto con anche delle case di
pregio
con una forte componente
multietnica
che ha avuto qualche passato qualche
problema proprio di relazione tra
diverse comunità di immigrati
e dove il tasso di criminalità tutto
sommato è decisamente basso se guardiamo
non solo la criminalità
ufficiale cioè quella riportata la
polizia ma anche quella
attraverso altri indagini e diciamo a
identificare la gente è terrorizzata
perché attraverso le interviste
scopriamo che la signora perché ha paura
paura e la violenza una donna più dense
di attività di milano
no no perché l'altra sera sono scese e
c'era una fila feti sono più in cui
fianco la mia casa ecco questo è un
problema legato all'uso lo spazio urbano
e alla mano e alla gestione lo spazio
urbano che è tra le principali cause
dell'insicurezza che abbiamo le nostre
città oggi non importa se due palazzi a
fianco viene scoperto e arrestato il
grande trafficante d'armi alla signora
anziana milanese fa più impressione
vedere magari la banda di ragazzotti che
vede fanno casino in maniera
assolutamente legale e magari soltanto
un po rumorosa
la sensazione di sicurezza disgiunta
dalle sicurezza reale quindi dovuta allo
squallore dello spazio urbano alla
mancanza di vitalità e qui purtroppo
dobbiamo dire che
la progettazione e soprattutto
l'urbanistica negli ultimi decenni
ci sono molto concentrate sugli aspetti
formali ignorando molto spesso quali
fossero poi gli eventi che potevano
accadere negli spazi che progettavano e
quindi quanti di voi hanno in mente
quella che chiamano cattedrali nel
deserto grandi piazze dove non succede
niente dove
vengono prese d'assalto dai vandali o
addirittura completamente anche dei
vandali quando una camminata diciamo che
quando in una piazza non ci sono nemmeno
i graffiti vuol dire che poi sbagliato
completamente
e la paura intesa come sentimento
soggettivo li rientra nelle
individualità delle persone le persone
hanno paura perché ognuno a modo proprio
c'è chi rimane terrorizzata dal
qualche giorno fa qualche settimana fa
sembrava che improvvisamente in tutta
l'india
le donne sono violentate come se fosse
la novità è
che abbiamo non so se avete visto dovuto
due settimane in cui ogni giorno ci
riportavano quanti sto per divenire ecco
questo è un po di influenza anche i
media che si concentrano sulle finte
notizie che è sorto alcune categorie di
persone hanno fatto molto forte
davanti a questa evoluzione del concetto
di paura c'è stata un'evoluzione del
concetto
della risposta all insicurezza
qui sarò sintetico allora la risposta ai
problemi in sicurezza oggi come oggi si
articola in secondo tre filoni
principali
quello istituzionale detto anche law and
order la polizia
attenzione la polizia che si è evoluta
non è più semplicemente la repressione
del fatto avvenuto la polizia e
moltissimi casi italia siamo molto
avanti su questo si è specializzata
anche in un diverso rapporto con la
cittadinanza in
processi di dialogo di comunicazione e
prevenzione del crimine per prevenzione
dal parola che sta davanti a tutto il
concetto di approccio di sicurezza
un approccio di tipo sociale quindi che
va a intervenire sulle cause umane del
disagio quindi in sicurezza
e più recente un approccio di tipo
ambientale quindi legato al luogo
io vi parlerò riso brevemente cos'è
l'approccio ambientale in quanto sono un
architetto non sono né un sociologo e un
poliziotto
allora l'approccio ambientale nasce da
una rivoluzione doveva tagliare tutto
però preferisco resiste analisi da una
rivoluzione nelle teorie criminologiche
e tradizionalmente studiavano il crimine
come un risultato di un'interazione tra
un aggressore una vittima e con un
processo che oggi sembra sembra banale
detto così sembra
per ciò che poteva arrivarci anch'io più
tutti potevano arrivarci ci sono voluti
50 anni ancora non è accettato
un'evoluzione che vede il crimine
parliamo di primi la mia realtà parliamo
in generale di insicurezza come un
interazione tra un aggressore o un
potenziale aggressore una vittima una
potenziale vittima e un contesto quindi
il riconoscimento dell'importanza del
luogo in cui
sicurezza si genera come uno degli
attori che partecipano a questo processo
l'assioma su cui il nostro lavoro si
basa è e l'organizzazione
l'organizzazione dello spazio e della
città influisce sulla sicurezza dei
luoghi può contribuire a renderli molto
più sicuri ma può anche essere
determinante nel renderli meno sicuri
questo perché
organizza strutturare bene uno spazio
uno spazio può intanto aumentare quello
che viene indetta sorveglianza spontanea
da parte dei cittadini la sorveglianza
spontanea un concetto
nato dalle delle teorie dagli altri
scritti di jane jacobs è un economista e
antropologa americana che negli anni
sessanta scrivere un libro bellissimo
che consiglio chi non lo conosca già che
è vita e morte delle grandi città
americane nel quale da
un'osservazione una città con un taglio
completamente diverso a quanto fatto
finora
crea un senso di appartenenza rispetto
al territorio
allora le persone che vino in un
territorio di cui si sentono
padroni tra virgolette e quindi i
responsabili se ne prendono cura si
sentono più più sicuri sono più
confidence in questo territorio
questo cosa vuol dire che il territorio
indipendentemente dalla sua buona o
cattiva progettazione indipendentemente
dalla sua bellezza che è soggettiva è
più adatto ad ospitare
le persone anche e soprattutto le
persone che in quel territorio che in
quello spazio arrivano casualmente e non
sono familiari con lo spazio questo
importantissimo ad esempio nei nodi di
traffico che l'interscambio in quei
luoghi dove la maggior parte degli
utenti sono in una co presenza non una
convivenza e ci rimangono per poco non
ho tempo di capire che tipo di luogo sia
allora un luogo ben tenuto genera nelle
persone un meccanismo
quasi non cosciente di questo tipo se
qui c'è qualcuno che si prende cura di
questo spazio vuol dire che si prenderà
cura anche di me qualora avessi bisogno
questo è il processo che si genera una
teoria ogni tanto mai sui giornali con
il nome di teoria delle finestre rotte
e quindi una buona organizzazione allo
spazio contribuisce a diminuire la
sensazione di insicurezza e di paura
facilità anche il lavoro delle forze
dell'ordine questa
uno strumento che usiamo per convincere
poi gli enti polizia collaborare con noi
nella progettazione
io vi risparmierà o una lunga serie di
principi fondamentali di saltiamo perché
mancano 20 secondi quindi
mi basta raccontarvi che davanti dopo
questo apparato
disciplinare teorico tutto sommato
semplice ma che ha impiegato appunto 50
anni per svilupparsi sono stati si sono
calati anche gli strumenti operativi
esistono oggi delle tecniche
sia per rilevare la potenziale di
sicurezza o di insicurezza di spazi a
partire dalle loro caratteristiche
fisiche quindi si possono dare degli
indicatori che poi portano a dare una
valutazione di quanto uno spazio possono
essere sicuro sia esistono delle
normative esiste una normativa europea
che indica dei principi guida su come
costruire e progettare uno spazio
tenendo conto di quello che all'interno
di questo spazio avviene in un'ottica di
sicurezza e quindi ritengo anche
come uno stretto legame per quanto
riguarda conviventi grazie